you simply can't make a superhero film
without relying on the work of visual
effects artists to some degree
but the level of reliance in the modern
age has reached heights that it can be
difficult to really understand
unless you see the original footage with
your own eyes
christopher nolan is known for taking a
practical approach to effects whenever
possible
but even he turns to the vfx team from
time to time
visual effects co-supervisor dan glass
revealed that the movie had nearly 600
effects
shots one of the most challenging jobs
that glass and his partner yanexer's
faced
was making the batmobile look convincing
which they achieved through a mixture of
trick shots and miniatures
the miniatures they created weren't
actually that many at all
they made a three-quarter scale five
foot batmobile glass explained
the key with miniatures is scale and
yannick pushed hard to use large
miniatures
some were 35 feet tall uk-based visual
effects house double negative
completed half of the 600 effects shots
in the movie and it was nominated at the
visual effects society awards for its
efforts
[Music]
so what do you think does it come in
black
keanu reeves relationship with the
hollywood press has always been love
hate
2005's constantine was one of the hate
moments as the majority of movie critics
bashed the supernatural dc flick
the film suffered from a fundamental
change deep into production
according to deke ferend hatch fx
co-founder and lead matt painter
he explained we began working on
constantine in april of 2004
the original delivery was set for the
end of july however in mid-july as we
were finalizing the final composites
there was a drastic change in direction
which resulted in starting a new concept
base
fans of the green lantern first started
to worry about the adaptation when they
discovered that hal jordan's suit was to
be made entirely from cgi so that the
vfx teams would have some flexibility
with the design
ryan reynolds wore a tracking suit and
all the effects were added in
after filming so how they did that was
using a motion capture suit which has
all these dots and you look like a crash
test dummy
in the end the suit itself was passable
but the unnatural looking mask wound up
ruining the overall effect
while many people pointed to the
substandard cgi reynolds
blamed the script for the film's
failings revealing that it hadn't even
been written when he signed on to star
he told yahoo when we shot green lantern
nobody auditioning for the role of green
lantern was given the opportunity to
read the script because the script
didn't exist
in the end most audiences had the same
reaction
three years after debuting as the man of
steel henry cavill was back in the red
cape and facing off against ben
affleck's batman
according to scanline's vfx supervisor
brian herota
director zack snyder came to him with an
idea for a montage that showed superman
saving people
all over the world which he wanted to
intercut with news stations debating
whether or not the kryptonian was
welcome on earth henry cavill was
digitally dropped into numerous
dangerous situations and natural
disasters
one of which was a huge flood while the
finished product looks pretty convincing
it turns out it was shot on an asphalt
backlot in michigan
perota told artavfx in post we used our
flowline software to simulate the river
and debris going around the houses
we extended the environment with added
extra houses trees and distant mountain
ranges
after that it was simply a matter of
dropping superman into the mix
and just like that you have a disastrous
flood
it bombed hard with critics but dc's
anti-hero ensemble suicide squad still
made a ton of money
a lot of visual effects went into the
film so much that the load had to be
divided between 17 different vfx houses
one such company was mpc whose workload
included harley quinn's elevator fight
scene
npc visual effects supervisor seth mori
told art of vfx
plates were shot of hardly fighting with
a practical actor our goal was to
replace the heads on these practical
actors so that the eyes on the head were
alive and blinking during each shot and
so that the head breathed and pulsed
mori revealed that his favorite part of
the sequence was blowing up these heads
every one of which was unique down to
the last detail
the dc extended universe was given a
breath of fresh air with wonder woman
the film looked great thanks in no small
part to the work of effects companies
like mpc
who contributed around 500 visual
effects shots led by vfx supervisor
jessica norman
the mbc team helped create the epic
beach battle the no man's land sequence
and several other action scenes the
company's website reveals
the beach battle sequence was shot on
the west coast of italy across two
beaches
npc's environmental artists extended the
beach and added cliff
backdrops cliffs and islands were lit
and rendered by npc's lighting team
npc also developed quote new controls
for hair simulations to be able to
maintain the shape and style of wonder
woman's hair in these action-packed
scenes
there was a time when an actor's hair
was the responsibility of makeup alone
but in the age of superhero blockbusters
every strand is subject to scrutiny from
the visual effects department
while it might not have lived up to the
standard set by wonder woman justice
league still
fared better with the critics than the
first three films in the franchise
the movie seemed destined to fail after
zack snyder left the project before the
shoot was done
marvel stalwart joss whedon stepped in
to finish the film but the result was a
hodgepodge of styles that didn't work as
well as warner brothers might have
imagined
the film's visual effects become a huge
talking point especially when it was
revealed that warner brothers was forced
to digitally remove a mustache that
henry cavill had grown from mission
impossible fallout
because paramount refused to let him
shave it for justice league reshoots
it comes and goes some of the cgi on
caval's upper lip was downright awful
with his mouth looking particularly
deformed in the film's opening moments
an unnamed justice league vfx artist
said it shouldn't have been improved
internally let alone gone all the way to
make it into film
well you know what they say about
mustaches easy to lose
if you dig around it's usually close by